foreign
hey folks welcome to the Dark Horse
podcast live stream number 163 I am Dr
Brett Weinstein this is Dr Heather Hein
and uh I believe that we have arrived at
the conclusion that not only is 163
Prime but it is some kind of ultra Prime
is that right it's fantastically Prime
it's it's amazingly priming it seems
like Prime already gets you there yeah
like privacy is really unambiguous but
then it turns out that there are
categories within Prime which we
probably should have seen coming yeah
totally but we didn't
um yeah so this week uh we're gonna talk
about uh what's going on in the world a
little bit
um seems Seems like a good idea yes
including excuse me
um a a newly published opinion uh that
what went wrong with regard to Public
Health policy in the pandemic uh was
that there was too much focus on
um individual health and uh individual
doctors and not enough on the collective
um we are also going to continue a
little bit the conversation from last
week with regard to uh your framing of
the product of science being models
which computer models but models models
with which you which you can then take
out into the world and uh and
extrapolate if that's your thing
as it should be yep as yeah it's it I
mean once you start extrapolating it's
hard to stop indeed uh and then we're
also going to talk a little bit about
race at the end of the show right you
know that you have that in mind all
right so a race to the Finish
no not really that kind of racist no but
it is spelled the same way indeed yes
it's gonna be that kind of day it often
is yes yes now we know no we do know yep
um now I also know why the cats have
made themselves scarce because they know
yeah
unless it's a race to tuna we're not in
right no no okay they're not racing cats
they race
they do yeah they race around but they
don't it would be hard to get them you
know that's the thing about herding cats
and racing cats has the same problem
yeah
we follow these live streams with live q
and A's I guess you can ask questions at
darkhorsesmissions.com I encourage you
to check out Natural Selections this
week I wrote about the age of censorship
that we are clearly living in oh I
forgot to bring actually Zach you want
to hand me the box set of the world doll
books that I've got on the on the desk
there uh we we didn't talk about last
week but uh what had just emerged from
uh the telegraph in London did an
amazing set of a bit of Journalism on
the newest
um
the newest censorship under the guise of
sensitivity readers on Roald Dahl's
entire Uber and I went and found
um this box set that I had bought for
our children probably 15 years ago and
uh went and compared what's in there to
what's in some of the uh
in some of the new the new edits and was
um was stunned in a number of ways
um not just the obvious like you're
dumbing it down you're erasing history
you know you're you're doing things that
will make it much more difficult to
learn from where we have been and
actually become better in the future but
also found some things that struck me in
the original as you know icky like oh I
don't um you know I kind of wish that
wasn't there but it's there so what you
do is you leave it there in pieces that
are published and uh you if you're
reading it to a child or if a child is
reading it on their own and it raises
questions for them you discuss it you
talk about the the things that are in
fiction that weren't written literally
yesterday but 10 15 100 200 years ago
and you talk about what that means about
how humans change and cultures change
and social mores change if I might add
it is also vital the key lesson when you
go back to something whether it's Dr
Seuss or Roald Dahl or Mark Twain or any
of these things and you find something
that your modern sensibilities shudder
at
the real message is you're probably
doing that right now
right you're probably doing something
that enlightens people in the future
will look back and say you know how
could they not have seen it yeah but
they didn't and the point is if you
erase that stuff from the stuff of the
past it gives you the impression that
we've arrived someplace that we
manifestly have not we may have been
headed someplace and now we're moving in
the wrong direction but the idea that
you have a right to understand to be
able to go back and actually even just
map the ignorance of the past in order
to understand what your own probable
ignorance looks like in the present
right to Rob us of that is so insane
it's it's anti-educational
it imagines uh that we have arrived at
the state of Purity and that we have
full Insight full access to all that is
good and right and full understanding of
all that is wrong and bad and that all
we have to do is cleanse cleanse the
past pretend it didn't happen certainly
don't let the children be exposed to
anything that now passes for wrong think
and then what
then they will grow up incapable of
thinking for themselves and capable of
recognizing actually bad ideas when they
show up it'll they'll be more likely to
succumb to them when they show up
outside of your view you sensors and
sensitivity readers and fact Checkers
and all the rest of the crazy names that
sensors are going under now you you will
actually
um hobble and [__] the children whom
you are pretending to be working on
behalf of it's It's the exact opposite
so anyway I wrote about that
um in Natural Selections this week
and we want to remind you that we are
supported by you and we encourage you to
subscribe to the channel where whatever
you're wherever you're listening uh and
if you're uh seeing if you're watching
Clips or if you feel like there's a
piece of what we do today that you'd
really like to share but maybe the whole
thing is too much check out our Clips
Channel at Dark Horse podcast Clips at
uh on either YouTube or Odyssey and
um and those are those are always
available and being generated constantly
by our awesome Clips producer and you
can also consider joining one of our
patreons tomorrow
um at my patreon we have our monthly
private q a which is lovely and we
interact with uh with the audience uh
there because it's it's small and small
enough to do so and you can also get
access to our Discord community and
either of our patreons and engage uh
with wonderful people on difficult
topics uh and any number of media
actually about three text audio
wonderful people on difficult topics not
difficult people on wonderful topics I
think there are wonderful topics and you
know honestly we're all difficult in our
own ways so I imagine uh that that some
of the people there might even be
considered uh particularly difficult and
you know so might you so might I but no
I will stick with the framing of
wonderful people on and not entirely
difficult topics but including difficult
topics would it be fair to say that I
have an easier time being difficult than
most people
I really have no idea how easy it is for
you you may be working very hard at it
you know that's a fair point
I think this was actually a reasonable
demonstration of the process right here
and you you did swimmingly oh thank you
thank you well the cat is in the
background wondering what we're on about
and the dog is snoring in case you hear
that's not our producer we haven't put
him to sleep yet that's the dog okay
um and of course we have sponsors all of
whom uh make products or services that
we actually and truly vouch for three at
the top of every hour every live stream
um and without further Ado here we go
our first sponsor this week is new to us
it is Helix Helix makes fantastic
mattresses that are supremely sleep
enhancing
we've had our Helix mattress for a month
now and it's amazing what a difference
an excellent mattress can make for good
sleep our animals love it too a little
too much Maddie our Labrador is not
allowed on the bed and she knows it but
we know that she takes naps on the new
Helix mattress when we're not around
it's that good
okay to be fair Labradors will sleep
anywhere and eat anything so maybe
that's not as much of an endorsement as
you might think but we can make an
endorsement and we are yeah they're
mattress [__] that's not they totally
are yeah I mean she's sleeping right now
on the floor exactly yeah seriously
though Helix sleep is a premium mattress
ban brand that offers 14 different
mattresses based on your unique sleep
preferences you take this Helix sleep
quiz online and in less than two minutes
you'll be directed to which of their
mini mattresses is best for you do you
sleep on your back your stomach or your
side do you toss and turn or sleep like
a log do you prefer a firmer or softer
mattress all of these are taken into
consideration with the Helix sleep quiz
excuse me
once you have found your perfect
mattress it ships straight to your door
free of charge
then you'll have 100 nights to try it
out without any penalty if you love it
which you almost certainly will they've
got 10 to 15 year warranties on all of
their mattresses Helix has models with
memory foam layers to provide optimal
pressure relief if you sleep on your
side and models with a more responsive
foam which provides optimal support for
stomach and back sleepers enhanced
cooling features keep you from
overheating at night and every Helix
mattress combines individually wrapped
steel coils in the base with premium
foam layers on top providing excellent
support for your spine and comfort for
all of you
Helix has been awarded the rank of
number one mattress by both GQ and Wired
Magazine and we can see why Helix
mattresses are made in America at their
very own manufacturing facility they're
built for human bodies and built to last
Helix also supports military First
Responders teachers and students by
giving them a special discount on site
we look forward to our Helix mattress
providing us with years of excellent
sleep you should look forward to yours
doing so as well Helix is offering up to
20 off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners go to
helixsleep.com Darkhorse and use promo
code Darkhorse that's Helix sleep
h-e-l-i-x sleep.com slash Darkhorse this
is their best offer yet and it won't
last long with Helix better sleep starts
now
okay our second sponsor this week is Ned
a CBD company that stands out in a
highly saturated CBD Market
Ned was started by two friends who
discovered their hyper modern lives were
leaving them feeling quote empty
bewildered and disconnected something
about this way of life they say just
wasn't working so they started Ned
you can buy CBD products in nearly every
coffee shop or grocery store these days
but Ned's Blends stand out I'm
particularly fond of their de-stress
blend Ned's distress blend is a
one-to-one formula of CBD and cpg made
from the world's purest full spectrum
hemp and also features a Botanical
infusion of Brett's favorite ashwagandha
cardamom and cinnamon someday
someday you'll go there yep CBG is known
as the mother of all cannabinoids
because of how effective it is at
combating anxiety and stress by
inhibiting the reuptake of Gaba which is
the neurotransmitter responsible for
stress regulation this combination
leaves me feeling a bit easier with
whatever comes my way
many of the CBD companies out there
Source their hemp from industrial farms
in China just like with low quality
alcohol however low quality CBD can have
undesired effects that is USDA certified
organic olive Ned's full spectrum hemp
oil is extracted from USDA certified
organic hemp plants grown by an
independent farmer named Jonathan in
Paonia Colorado
also Ned shares third-party lab reports
and information about who Farms their
products and their extraction process on
their site
these products are science-backed
nature-based solutions that offer an
alternative to prescription and
over-the-counter drugs they are chock
full of Premium CBD and a full spectrum
of active cannabinoids terpenes
flavonoids and trichomes now it's full
spectrum hemp oil nourishes the body's
endocannabinoid system to offer
functional support for stress sleep
inflammation and balance if you'd like
to give net a try Darkhorse listeners
get 15 off Ned products with code
Darkhorse visit helloned.com Darkhorse
to get access that's
h-e-l-l-o-n-e-d.com slash Darkhorse to
get 15 off thank you Ned for sponsoring
the show and offering our listeners a
natural remedy for some of life's most
common health issues
all right our final sponsor this week is
Vivo barefoot shoes made for feet
everyone should try these shoes most
shoes are made for someone's idea of
feet vivos however are made by people
with feet who know how to use them no
matter how many feet you have these
shoes are excellent although I should
point out it's a small company they only
sell them in pairs I was just going to
say I think I mean maybe you could get
something special going on but I'm
pretty sure they sell them on pairs they
sell them in pears absolutely
um one for each uh all right well word
is spreading uh Heather was approached
this last week by someone who recognized
the shoe she was wearing and was asked
if they were as good as this person had
heard and of course they are just that
good here at Darkhorse we love these
shoes they are Beyond comfortable the
tactile feedback from the surfaces you
are walking on is amazing they cause no
pain at all because there are no
pressure points forcing feet into odd
positions they're fantastic
our feet are the products of millions of
years of evolution humans evolve to walk
move and run Barefoot modern shoes that
are overly cushioned and strangely
shaped have negatively impacted foot
function and are contributing to a
Health crisis people move less than they
might in part because their shoes make
their feet hurt enter Vivo barefoot Vivo
barefoot shoes are designed wide to
provide natural stability then to enable
you to feel more and flexible to help
you build your natural strength from the
ground up foot strength increases by 60
percent in a matter of months just by
walking around in them the number of
people wearing Vivo barefoots is growing
as well once people start wearing these
shoes they don't seem to stop Vivo
Barefoot has a great range of Footwear
for kids and adults and for every
activity from hiking to training and
everyday wear they're a certified B Corp
that is pioneering regenerative business
principles and their Footwear is
produced using sustainably sourced
natural and recycled materials with the
aim to protect the natural world so you
could run wild upon it
go to Vivo barefoot.com use the code
darkhorse15 to get an exclusive 15 off
additionally all new customers get a 100
day free trial so you can see if you
love them as much as we do
that's
v-i-v-o-b-a-r-e-f-o-o-t.com and use the
code darkhorse15 at checkout
[Music]
okay let's start I should have drunk
some water while you were doing that let
us start it's never too late with water
I think there might be a moment at which
it was time there actually is a moment
but you're nowhere near it thank you
thank you yeah this is this is going to
be odd this week yeah I can I can tell
already the that slant to it yep yep
okay so
we're going to start this week by
talking about uh well by talking about
science and medicine and evolution and
the ways that these things interact and
how they are understood by
um by many people in these fields and by
the public generally and this is
prompted by there's an op-ed published
in stat on the 24th of this month so
that's that'll be yesterday
[Laughter]
called fixing U.S public health will
require a Health Systems Revolution and
for Physicians
to take a back seat well that's so the
headline is I'm going to read that with
the right intonation fixing U.S public
health will require a Health Systems
Revolution and for Physicians to take a
back seat
so the same author published a similar
piece in the nation uh which if you just
want to show my screen here for a moment
uh this is again same author Eric
Reinhardt this was published a couple
days earlier on February 22nd also this
week which is called want to fix Public
Health stop thinking like a doctor
Public Health requires seeing the world
from a collective perspective but U.S
agencies are still dominated by doctors
trained to work on an individual level
so uh I want to First
share a bit a couple of paragraphs from
this piece that strike me as well let me
just share a couple paragraphs first and
you can again show my screen if you like
Zach this is a PDF but it's exactly
that's it's the nation article
that came out this week by again Eric
Reinhardt in a section that he calls the
hazards of clinicism
when we treat patients doctors are
appropriately oriented around taking
care of the individual in front of us so
I should say that the author is an MD
when we treat patients doctors are
appropriately oriented around taking
care of the individual in front of us we
recognize that we typically cannot
change their life circumstances such as
economic and housing conditions
employers demands student and medical
debt neighborhood violence or social
isolation and so we focus our clinical
attention on helping them live as well
as possible within existing constraints
Public Health by contrast is about
treating populations as with medicine
the goal of Public Health is to enable
individuals to be free of Health
limitations that curtail their ability
to live as they please but Public Health
pursues this by very different means the
task is not to help individuals
accommodate to oppressive social or
labor contexts it is instead to use the
power of government to change conditions
that are constraining people's freedom
the core tools of Public Health then are
not just vaccines or lab tests but also
policies pertaining to corporate
regulation and consumer safety standards
labor protections public jobs and
housing programs investments in
community health workers
decriminalization and decarceration and
civil rights lawsuits
okay
um so you can
hear my screen back here let me just one
sentence in particular there jumped out
at me you know so far
um like this this seems broadly correct
the the arguments here uh he says
uh
the the role of Public Health is instead
to use the power of government to change
conditions that are constraining
people's freedom
yes
I'm surprised to hear that from someone
who is arguing or what amounts to a
curtailing of Greater freedoms
um that we had so much during the last
three years that amounted to uh in order
to get your lives back you're going to
need to give us some of what you've got
in order to be healthy in order to be
safe in order to ah than it went to in
order to keep Grandma healthy in order
to keep the children healthy in order to
keep Grandma healthy or Grandma safe and
the children safe then we're going to
need to curtail what it is that you're
allowed to do take some things away
don't worry we'll give them back later
unless we don't and you know this this
has been the the direction for three
years and the argument here would seem
to be seem to be that the problem has
been too much of a focus on the
individual and not enough on the
population and
um that that seems to me to be
indicative of having lived on a kind of
a different planet let's let's fix it
okay okay because I know exactly what's
being alleged here and uh my sense is so
far what they've said in principle is at
least not wrong but the problem is the
in principle it's a heat
what a thing
it it is a I will get back to defending
why it is a they later because although
it is authored by a he
um it is speaking for something else I
believe
but the the issue is here one of net
freedom right yeah it is not one of
instantaneously measured Freedom the
argument which was persuasive to many at
the beginning of the pandemic
was that in order to control the spread
of the virus and therefore free us from
it later we needed to give up freedoms
in the present that turned out to be
horseshit right it's not even obvious
that the people who were handing down
these policies were interested in us
controlling the pandemic they exploited
it for other reasons and that is a
terrifying story but nonetheless there's
nothing wrong with the idea that one
gives up some freedoms now in order to
have greater freedoms later one
surrenders to the TSA and to the
authority of those on an airplane in
order to have the freedom to go to some
far-off place ashwagandha or somewhere
else in order to see something they've
never seen before
um so anyway the point is trading a a a
reduction in Freedom now in order for
greater Freedom later is a perfectly
rational argument to make
and certainly it is true that public can
be a perfectly rational argument it is
not inherently a rational argument in
any place but there is nothing
irrational about making such an argument
it is not a non-sequitur and I will say
that Public Health
if it were to function is about this
very thing there is a conflict between
the individual level of health and the
collective level of Health that can
result in a paradoxical if you free the
individual it reduces the freedom of
individuals on a much larger scale this
this is true but um
it seems to me that the argument hinges
that that reinhardt's argument and yes
it is a bigger day that he is speaking
for right
um hinges on the idea that practitioners
of medicine and science throughout the
pandemic including and he calls out
fauci and balinski actually it's
interesting that we are now arriving
there right that he calls out uh
basically the heads of organizations
that helped make policy that many people
are finally beginning to recognize was
terrible
um you know almost across the board you
know I would say across the board but
many people are coming to realize that
it was at least many more of these
decisions were bad than than many people
believed at the time
he thinks that this is because uh that
these were individual scientists
pursuing individual
um you know things that were good for
individuals and my argument of course
our argument is has been for almost
three years
um that that's not that's not the
problem here that's not what went wrong
the what went wrong in part is that
science actually wasn't being done that
there was you know there were a lot of
the sort of uh markers of science there
I mean there was even fauci declaring
that he was science
and there were credentials and there
were you know there were papers that
looked really sciencey and when you went
into them they had lots of numbers in
them and all of this uh but it wasn't
actually a scientific approach to
understanding what was what was going on
and let me just one more little excerpt
here
before we get back to
um how else you wanted to fix these
first two
paragraphs that I read this is actually
from the paragraph just before in that
same Nation op-ed that I just read and
you can show my screen if you want to is
that but you don't have to he writes
physician and public health scholar
Milton Romer once observed that for the
work of Public Health quote most of
medical education is irrelevant
but neither doctors are relevant medical
knowledge nor relative ignorance of
essential Fields labor history social
anthropology political economy
epidemiology environmental Sciences is
the most troubling aspect of physician
control of Public Health
rather it's a lack of epistemic humility
conferring an inability to recognize the
limits and Hazards of clinical reasoning
with which medical training often abuse
them clinical real clinical reasoning is
not only not the population level logic
of Public Health it is frequently
antithetical to it
so
this to me like perfectly encapsulates
the problem with the conversation that
we've that we have been having that we
have been trying to have publicly and
that so many people so many of the
Talking Heads both in and outside of
medicine that are effectively
um you know making or enforcing the
public policy that's being handed down
to us
is making first of all look at the list
of things that he thinks need to be
included labor history social
anthropology political economy
epidemiology environmental Sciences
where's evolution
and I will talk a little bit more maybe
before I get into this but what I want
to talk about ultimately here why this
is coming up is that nowhere in any of
these conversations
is evolution actually showing up and
what what we have been doing for our
entire careers but um you know publicly
for three years almost three years now
is revealing why having an evolutionary
understanding of the world you're in and
how complex that means the complex
systems that you're engaging you know of
and with must be can actually help you
make informed decisions about your life
and the lives of your loved ones and and
and help you help you be
healthier and more productive going
forward so he's attacking the
clinical reasoning of wolinsky and fauci
and what I would say is we have seen no
evidence of clinical reasoning from them
or from the vast majority of doctors who
have been in lockstep with things like
mandates and definitely avoiding any
kind of effective treatment and you know
things like putting you know patients on
ventilators as we talked about uh last
last week on Dark Horse this isn't about
a failure of clinical reasoning
um or the this isn't about the limits of
clinical reasoning to solve public
health problems that may also be true
like you know the fields that he
mentions labor history and political
economy are relevant to a question of
how you know how is it if you're a
doctor and a patient comes in and you
can tell that their diet is crap but
they live in a food desert and there's
no way for them to get good food what
can you do for them right like what you
can't exactly tell them you need to
start eating you know steak and avocado
if they have no access to steak and
avocado Auto right so that is a problem
and that is a that is a conflict a
tension between individual Level Health
practitioners and uh and a society where
public health is actually in all of our
interest
but the problem with the covet response
was actually
deeper bigger and more fundamental than
what he is talking about here it was a
complete failure to think logically
rigorously scientifically and in any way
evolutionarily at basically at every
single level and time and time again we
got told stay in your lane it's like you
know what if vaccinology and
epidemiology and virology and you know
on and on and on and on and medical
Medical Science and all of these things
are failing because they are so
specialized that they can't tell what is
going on and we are coming in with a
generalist Paradigm that is evolutionary
analysis and it is time and time and
time again able to predict what is going
to happen next well then maybe everyone
in all of these fields
ought to be getting some background in
experience and thinking evolutionarily
and we would all be better off
I hate to disagree with you do you yes
but I've got to take you to task you're
being far too generous
um in other words it's worse than that
yeah
um and I want to resurrect an idea some
may have heard me invoke it before it's
originally a cybernetic idea but it is
so fundamentally important that
um it belongs squarely in the center of
this discussion okay it is posiwit the
purpose of a system is what it does okay
and what this says is it doesn't matter
purpose of system is what it does right
it's an acronym right what it means is I
don't care what that object claims to be
doing I don't even care what the people
who built the object think it does the
purpose of the object is what it does
and the reason that this is so important
is evolutionary which is that sometimes
even a system that is architected well
for a particular purpose if you build
the right characteristics into it will
evolve into something else and nobody
changes the label on it they assume it
does what it always did so my point is
going to be the purpose of our public
health system is apparently to override
doctors and inflict dangerous treatments
on people that are profitable
I don't know why that's the case or how
anybody allowed it to become the case
but it is demonstrably the case it is
the reason that we had a system and this
is the place that I am I know you know
this I'm not telling you anything you
don't know but the reason that I'm going
to push back a little bit
is that I don't think this was a failure
of our system this was the success of an
Undeclared system that overrode the
system we're supposed to have that's
supposed to protect the public health
that's the that's that's quite possible
that's you know that's I feel like
that's a they're all related
conversations
um but the but the the point that I'm
trying to to make here with regard to to
Reinhardt who as far as I know
it you know I don't know who he is as
far as I know is trying to make an
argument about the you know the
collective versus the individual levels
of analysis and he is making a claim
that science failed us that what what
has been revealed for the last three
years is that science can't get you
there and what we have been saying for
three years is no
you haven't tested that hypothesis yet
because science wasn't done here we need
actual science we need to actually do
science and
um I would can I can I invoke this now
um for instance here's here's why we get
sick uh the new science of darwinian
Medicine by Randolph Nessie and George
Williams
um Nessie was at Michigan when we were
at Michigan we actually did as I
remember we did like a semester-long
seminar in darwinian medicine with him
yep
um and we knew George Williams before
his death yep and George Williams is one
of the great evolutionary biologists of
the 20th century
and um and this book is is critical this
you know again it's called why we get
sick the new science of darwinian
medicine it is the best there is on this
topic and it was published in 1994. it
was published 29 years ago and there is
not another book that has that has come
in and uh and continued the conversation
and so um Nessie is actually an MD and
George Williams is a PhD in biology or
evolutionary biology and um excuse me
they they argue
correctly
um early to the game uh that medicine in
order to actually be good at treating
people needs to take an evolutionary
approach in all things not just to the
human body but to the interaction of the
human body with pathogens to the arms
races that happen between them to which
diseases that we experience are about
mismatches with our current environment
because of hyper novelty the term that
we we um coined in hunter-gatherer's
Guide to the 21st century which of them
are actually about trade-offs they're
intrinsic to our system and we ought to
choose a or b and neither of them are
great but you're gonna be stuck with the
trade-off like there are different ways
that our bodies do fail us and some of
them are avoidable and some of them
aren't but they can be mitigated and
this is this book does a fantastic job
of describing some of that so I just
want to read a brief excerpt again this
is a book published 29 years ago still
the best Treatise on the topic of
darwinian Medicine as far as as far as
I'm aware so from late in the book page
236 we have
this
why isn't this is at the near the end of
the book in which they've already laid
out argument after argument example
after example why isn't the body more
reliable why is there disease at all as
we have seen the reasons are remarkably
few first there are genes that make us
vulnerable to disease some though fewer
than has been thought are defectives
continually arising from new mutations
but kept scarce by natural selection
other genes cannot be eliminated because
they cause no disadvantages until it is
too late in life for them to affect
Fitness
antagonistic plyotropy as Brett you have
uh written about in your work on
telomeres cancer it's in essence
most deleterious genetic effects however
are actively maintained by selection
because they have unappreciated benefits
that outweigh their costs some of these
are maintained because of heterozygote
Advantage some are selected because they
increase their own frequency despite
creating a disadvantage for the
individual who Bears them some are
genetic quirks that have adverse effects
only when they interact with a novel
environmental Factor
second disease results from exposure to
novel factors that were not present in
the environment in which we evolved
given enough time the body can adapt to
almost anything but the 10 000 years
since the beginnings of civilization are
not nearly enough time and we suffer
accordingly infectious agents evolve so
fast that our defenses are always a step
behind
third disease results from design
compromises such as upright posture with
its Associated back problems
fourth we are not the only species with
adaptations produced and maintained by
natural selection which works just as
hard for pathogens trying to eat Us in
the organisms we want to eat
in conflict with these organisms as in
baseball you can't win them all finally
disease results from unfortunate
historical legacies if the organism had
been designed with the possibility of
Fresh Starts and major changes there
would be better ways of preventing many
diseases alas every successive
generation of the human body must
function well with no chance to go back
and start it fresh this is a sort of an
opaque reference to Adaptive landscapes
finally the human body turns out to be
both fragile and robust like all
products of organic evolution it is a
bundle of compromises Each of which
offers an advantage but often at the
price of susceptibility to disease these
susceptibilities cannot be eliminated by
any duration of natural selection for it
is the very power of natural selection
that created them
that's the sentence that I wanted to get
to here you will find
go into any scientific paper or medical
paper right now go on to Twitter and
find the the medical professionals and
researchers talking about they've got
the Breakthrough they're going to cure
cancer they're going to cure aging
they've got the vaccine that's going to
stop everything in its tracks and see
how hubristic they are and how the the
failure to understand that natural
selection got us there and it's still
working and it's going to continue to to
move forward in time as with regardless
of what we throw at that you know this
this Assumption of a stable background
onto which we can apply our treatments
is not just arrogant but incredibly
weak-minded like it really
misunderstands the landscape that we're
in as an evolved and evolving landscape
yeah it
um the medical approach
in isolation of an evolutionary
understanding results in us being
upended again and again by our failure
to appreciate the complexity of the
system which we are very unlikely to
improve upon right we can do certain
things our best tricks are borrowed from
Evolution itself right antibiotics are
miraculous but we don't make them those
antibiotics come from chemical warfare
between bacteria and fungi right and we
borrow them surgery marvelous but
surgery doesn't work on your car why not
because it is entirely contingent on the
ability of the body to fix itself after
you slice it open and pull something out
or modify something so you know it is a
recognition of the complexity of the
system and the um
the nature of the ratio that makes you
far more likely to screw the thing up
than than improve upon it that is the
basis of the correct thinking and the
this is now uh flipping that order on
its head exactly let me just just
because you because you just went there
yep one more little excerpt this time
from our book a hunter-gatherers Guide
to the 21st century in which we devote
one
two-ish but really you know one chapter
to medicine and another to sort of the
human body and Form and Function more
generally
um we say in the chapter on medicine
nothing in biology makes sense except in
the light of evolution said biologist
theodocious dubchansky this is famous uh
you know that that quote shows up in why
we get sick in most books that talk
about Revolution at all so that's dubs
dub chansky from 1963 nothing in biology
makes sense except in the light of
evolution we write medicine is
biological and it's heart that does not
mean though that most medical research
being done is evolutionary in its
thinking or in the questions being asked
combine a tendency to engage only
proximate questions with a bias towards
reductionism and you end up with
medicine that has blinders on the view
is narrow even the great victories of
Western medicine surgery antibiotics and
vaccines have been over extrapolated
applied in many cases where they
shouldn't be when all you have is a
knife a pill and a shot the whole world
looks as though it would benefit from
being cut and medicated
and just a reminder that we actually
submitted the first draft of this book
and that chapter didn't change much
just before covid was hitting just
before lockdowns in
early March of 2020. that was written
before covet and uh and
it's it's still true
so
good so there a few connections I want
to draw here and I want to recover the
idea that this is really a they giving
voice to a perspective through an
individual who has authored this
um wrong-headed piece but I want to
point out when we spoke last week about
the value what is produced by science
being models that are robust enough to
extrapolate from I want to point out
that the um the idea that we are giving
voice to here in a medical context has a
famous quote that people our audience is
very likely to know from a totally
different context from a totally
different source of absolutely
non-medical source and that is Thomas
soul
Thomas Soul says there are no Solutions
only trade-offs okay now what that means
is that why is he saying that he's
saying that because he is in he is
interfacing with a complex system and
the point is you you if you're
interfacing with a complex system you
either get this most fundamental point
or you're going to be you know making
infantile mistakes until you get it
because it's the it's the Baseline if
you've got a functional complex system
then the point is you probably don't
know nearly enough about the
consequences of the intervention you
naively think is going to improve things
yeah which then brings us to this
question about
really the the title of that piece right
doctors taking a back seat
now here's the thing
Public Health
is the recognition that there are
trade-offs between the individual level
and the scaled up version over a society
that's real
the problem is how good are we at
solving those larger scale problems and
I find it essentially diabolical
that they would go after what just
happened to us as a demonstration that
really we need to double down on public
health because what they did is they
silenced the doctors right they silenced
the doctors and they did something in
lieu of Public Health right it was
Pharma corruption that spoke as if it
was trying to solve a public health
problem
that caused so much harm and what I
believe that article is whether the
author knows it or not and the author
may well not know it the author may just
simply be following a signal that
something needs to be given voice but
that voice is Pharma having captured the
system now trying not to be ushered out
the door on the basis of all the harm
that was done saying well that wasn't
real Public Health right what we really
need to do is get rid of those people
who screwed up the public health
response and do some real Public Health
it's interesting that actually in at
least one of those two articles by the
same author published within a couple
days of each other in Staten and the
nation
um he has
um primary corruption and uh and and
perverse incentives maybe not named
exactly that way but he he calls out
Pharma uh which you know is exactly it's
part of why I focused on the nation uh
article you know we
we were long time uh subscribers to the
nation and uh criticism of the role that
Pharma had in public health was one of
the things that I had come to expect
from them and that we have seen from
nowhere on the left you know for the
last three years and finally we're
beginning to get these little
intimations and you know it's going to
come with some whitewashing and some
disappearing of history and some
pretending and some lying and that's you
know that's some stuff that we would
we're gonna try to make sure it doesn't
happen
um by by those who would like to pretend
that they got it right all along uh but
okay if if the nation is coming back to
its roots in which it understands uh
that those things that have power will
try to protect their power and therefore
you can't take literally all the things
that they tell you about what they're
doing and why they're doing it uh then
maybe we can get back to some kind of
conversation about what has actually
happened well I've got to tell you I'm
struggling not to be cynical about this
but I take pieces like that one that at
this moment would double down on a
so-called Public Health A system that
has just failed in this way I take them
as part of what we have called the
middle ground scramble and the idea is
nobody at this moment is going to be
taken seriously in any conversation if
they don't scold Pharma right so the
scolding of Pharma is obligate in a
piece like this in order for Pharma to
keep its captured entity and to continue
to sideline doctors who at the end of
the day have to face the patients and
the fact is medicine has a
multi-thousand year history
right we have some successes in public
health and we have some spectacular
failures covid is a spectacular failure
and so the idea of sidelining doctors
after you've just shut doctors up in an
effort to advance the public health
agenda which turned out to be a Pharma
agenda which did all of this harm is
absolutely insane and the you know the
excuse is basically a well real
communism hasn't ever been tried kind of
excuse right we now we have to start
Public Health right after we've paid
this huge Global price and the answer is
no can we at least go back to doctors
who swear an oath not to harm their
patients
right so I I fear that we're talking a
little bit about crop at Cross purposes
I want to get back to talking about
Evolution and and the fact that uh the
the public health policy the doctors uh
who are making the policy and her who
are actually interacting with patients
mostly don't know how to think
evolutionarily yep and that that that is
the core problem and so just one example
that that we have been talking about for
a long time is that most people
including most doctors but including
perhaps especially the many of the
intellectuals and so-called
intellectuals out there including those
with medical and scientific training
um actually make claims like why does it
matter where SARS Kobe 2 came from like
it what could it possibly matter it's
irrelevant to how we respond to it right
like we were hearing this back in 2020
and we're continuing to hear it now it's
ridiculous and I went back and I think
that the first time but it may not have
been the first time that we specifically
talked about this we talked about it
over and over and over again why does
the origin of the virus matter in terms
of how the virus will then act in humans
continue to evolve and what and and
therefore should be used to inform how
we actually act at a public health level
on July 14 2020 on Dark Horse live
stream number 30 that time stamp 30
minutes and 39 seconds and I'll put this
into the show notes you start discussing
why and how a lab origin may explain why
the virus acts the way it does with
regard to effects on children and
transmission outdoors and other things
so that's in July of 2020 and I'm not
sure that was the first time you were
talking about it or we were talking
about it but I know that at least it
happened at least that far at least then
and we've been talking about it ever
since and using an evolutionary
understanding of okay if not zoonotic
because from almost the very beginning
it's the evidence is pointed not
zoonotic but lab origin what else can we
say about what is going to happen next
that is part of what we have been doing
that is part of the model that we have
been using which guess what was
available to anyone who wanted it and
and you know this is part of why I you
know I agree with you this doesn't look
like an error because you know this it
doesn't cost money
um it takes some practice and it takes
some patience and it takes being willing
to be wrong and to rethink you know when
you arrive at some place that is wrong
and go back to the last place on which
you are certain that you're on firm
intellectual ground and go okay well
let's take the other Branch then like
you have to be doing that all the time
and most people feel like ah it's all I
do I don't have time that makes me look
weak something but you we need it like
we need all the people who are making
decisions on behalf of any of the rest
of us to absolutely 100 be willing to
have exactly what the author of this
piece calls epistemic humility but like
actual epistemic humility not the kind
uh that he is asking for the kind that
he needs to and that all of these people
need and the and that we have like that
we need and we and you need to
constantly check in with yourself be
like help you know am I wrong how would
I know who can I ask what can I check
with in terms of you know how many of
the views that I hold are inconsistent
and do it all the time that's the thing
it doesn't end you don't get to like do
this and then be like okay I did I
graduated I'm done thinking for myself
now now I'm an expert now now I'm an
expert and what I believed on that day
of graduation is always true shall
always be true nothing ever shall change
because my degree says so like that's
not how the world Works no and and uh if
I might this epistemic humility thing is
going to become very important and I'm
I'm concerned that this abuse of it it's
like evidence-based medicine like who
wouldn't be in favor of evidence-based
medicine until you dig and you discover
that evidence-based medicine doesn't
mean evidence-based medicine right right
um so anyway the point is epistemic
humility involves building a circuit in
which you are very sensitive to evidence
that you have something important wrong
and you are highly motivated to Chase it
down so that as quickly as possible you
can fix the error and stop being wrong
exactly right and so does that process
end absolutely not right what you do is
you get closer and closer to right which
means you get closer and closer to a
model that is more and more predictive
while assuming less that's the whole
point of the exercise and anybody who
thinks that they've got this wired and
now they need to tell doctors to sit
down right is not displaying epistemic
humility they're displaying the opposite
they're displaying a kind of arrogance
which they would like to of course cloak
in the idea of humility because it's
very attractive to do that but it's not
right it's it is you are putting us in
danger for the next one exactly and I
mean I'm reminded I mean this is
this is a theme this is a drum beat of
ours but um this piece that I wrote
you know what if we're wrong uh it was
first published in area and then I
republished it on my on my sub stack
specifically goes goes after
um the certainty
that so many people seem to have and you
know ironically it is our supposed
certainty that people attack us for and
it is their certainty of things that
we've said that we never said uh that is
the basis for a lot of these you know
freezy beliefs and accusations and
frankly at different levels in different
places policies that are being that are
being implemented so
why are
doctors you know it's it's one thing to
say okay most people don't understand
how to think evolutionarily uh it's not
necessarily widespread in high school or
college curricula even you know even if
you're a biology major maybe you had you
know a course maybe right so still
though it seems like doctors you know if
if
if we're right and if Nessie and
Williams are right and why we get sick
and everything about us is the product
and products of evolution
obviously doctors should be
um trained in practiced in skilled in
understanding how to think
evolutionarily
so I did a little
search on medical school curricula in
the U.S and I just pulled up five first
I first I Googled and the first one that
came up was uh Drexel University's
College of Medicine and then I went you
know what I'm going to actually just
pick four more not randomly but out of
my head so I went and looked at Stanford
University of Florida and Gainesville
Harvard Drexel and the University of
Washington
um here in Washington state and Seattle
and uh searched and I don't have clear
visuals so I'm just going to walk us
through this I basically looked for the
curriculum that is required for all
medical students and to the degree that
it was available tried to search on all
of the courses offered but
specifically searched on not just the
names of courses but the course
descriptions for all of when it was
available first second third fourth year
coursework and all the required
coursework and I searched on the word
Evolution and then I also searched on
just the just Evo because evolutionarily
evolutionary right could show up
at Stanford there are many different
Pathways possible every med student
takes the same course as the first year
they do have a social justice and Health
Equity curriculum which is prominently
displayed but the word Evolution even
the wrote the the root EVO shows up
zero times
at Stanford
University of Florida College of
Medicine the required courses Year One
no Evolution you're two
no Evolution year three and four nope
none never
okay Harvard Medical School core courses
no mention and again I'm not just
looking at titles of courses I'm looking
at course descriptions I'm searching on
course descriptions here
nothing
The Drexel College of Medicine
nope
how about the University of Washington
School of Medicine
um no they make it a little bit harder
to assess because they've got all these
different Pathways but uh but no none of
the pages I landed on could I find a
single there was one page on one of
these sites where Evo showed up
but it was within the word developing so
that doesn't count right right uh so
literally five and this is some of the
top medical schools in the country and
some that aren't
um
five medical schools in the U.S right
now with regard to their required and to
some degree as much as I was able to
find it they're not required but if
you're interested in this that or the
other curriculum
make no mention of evolution anywhere in
the coursework and that's not to say of
course that some of these classes once
you're in it might occasionally
reference Evolution I assume that they
do but it's that referencing which is to
say of course we all know that and
therefore we all understand that we are
evolved but frankly most people who
think they believe in evolution don't
have any idea what they're doing they
don't know how it works they don't know
how to think evolutionarily and it's how
you get to
people imagining that clinical work was
going on here with with covet it wasn't
this was this was not in any way
informed by what we actually are as
evolved human beings this whole three
years none of it it flew in the face
yeah and that is in some sense the story
of what we did is we just constantly
checked reality against uh an
evolutionary model and what was being
advised never made any sense which
alarmed us to a greater and greater
degree yes
um I did want to point out you you it
may or may not be easy for you to find
but that sentence that you said was a
cryptic reference to Adaptive Landscapes
oh yeah it's relevant here if you can
find it I think I can
uh this was in page 236 here we go um
it's like the last sentence in what
you're almost there was the previous
paragraph but
um
if the organism has two if the organism
had been designed with the possibility
of fresh start some major changes there
would be better ways of preventing many
diseases alas every successive
generation of the human body must
function well with no chance to go back
and start afresh perfect is that it yeah
now here's the reason I want to
resurrect that again as with the Thomas
Soul quote that happens to apply to
biology or vice versa
um
the quote you've just read There is a
reference to what you and I would
technically call historical contingency
and an engineer might call Path
dependence okay now I want to point out
that the and by the way it's not just
that five medical schools make no
mention of it it's five of five that you
looked at exactly I I could have kept
going you could have kept going what I
mean like I would love I would love to
have anyone who's who says you know
actually this medical school is the
exception yeah it would be great to know
if it exists I've been saying for I
don't know how long decades that
um that medicine is still taught as if
Darwin had never published yes um
exactly and so anyway why is that now I
want to give them their due I want to
explain where that initially came from
because it did have a good reason at
first
and then it no longer has a good reason
and we are now paying a tremendous price
to the non-evolutionary nature of
medicine okay
the problem is
um you
discover a powerful principle like
natural selection you know 1859 Darwin
finally publishes what he's been working
on the world is suddenly aware of
something it can be sort of summed up in
a paragraph but it's really not clear
what it implies about medicine if you
were to say aha suddenly we know what we
are surely that impacts medicine let's
go back and revise the curriculum you
know three weeks after Darwin published
you would be more likely to do harm than
good yeah right because there wasn't
enough understanding of what the
implications what Darwin had said was
too crude you don't add the new stuff to
the Core Curriculum right away right so
my point is initially there is a reason
for doctors not to jump at Evolution
even though in a philosophical sense it
was obvious that it would ultimately
have tremendous implications and that
frankly medicine should start with
selection right every medical curriculum
on Earth should start with this because
it is riddled throughout it whether you
mention it or not whether you understand
it or not right clonal selection the the
way in which a vaccine induces immunity
is a sped up version of literal genetic
Evolution inside the body right if you
don't understand the nuances of how
selection works then you're not going to
understand clonal selection and you're
going to just see vaccination as a kind
of a black box that induces something
important that fems off disease and
you're going to screw up when they try
to feed you something that doesn't work
this way or it doesn't properly work
this way or they have to use an adjuvant
because what they gave you isn't good
enough to induce the response or any of
these things so anyway at first
there is a reason for doctors not to
jump at Darwinism but then it becomes a
territorial question and they get used
to not thinking evolutionarily even as
evolutionary thinking catches up and
then overtakes medicine with its
capacity to say something about what is
likely to do more harm than good right
so we are still dealing with a several
thousand year old oath to do no harm but
the principle that would allow you to
see where harm is before you do it is
not invoked in any core way in medical
curricula which is frightening at this
point right that historical contingency
is resulting Us in us not going back and
saying well
it's 2023
maybe it's time to rewrite the medical
curriculum in light of all of the things
that we have now learned about the way
Evolution works right it wasn't ready in
1859 in 2023 it's long overdue and it's
not like the field of evolutionary
medicine hasn't progressed since the
publishing of that book but what it has
been done is it what has been done is it
been segregated the point is it is
treated as non-medical the same way
evolutionary psychology is treated
outside of the clinical practice right
the point is it's an abstraction oh it's
very nice that we can think in a
darwinian way about medicine no it's not
very nice it's fundamentally important
when you go into your doctor's office in
fact it's not an add-on it's not an
add-on I believe that book has a
terrible piece of advice uh from Richard
Dawkins on the back uh
does it say something about uh buy two
copies and give one to your doctor buy
two copies and give one to your doctor I
know this is terrible advice because I
did it
you can imagine how that went over well
uh oh so okay I don't know what to ask
well I mean basically the point is it is
taken as an affront it is taken as a
challenge to somebody's expertise rather
than a hey you and I are in parallel
Fields I'm not in no position to to tell
you about medicine but I am in a
position to tell you about something
that I know isn't included in that
medicine and this might change your
thinking right so anyway
um your doctor wasn't appreciative no my
doctor was not appreciative which I get
right but nonetheless my doctor well I
don't know if my doctor went on to read
it or not but my doctor assuming that
his initial reaction was indicative they
missed an opportunity he didn't throw it
he just looked at me like I had walked
in from Mars
um
but in any case
half dependence
that is a feature of a Model A model of
developing systems medicine is a
developing system the human body is a
developing system it's not surprising
the path dependence ends up a relevant
piece of uh to the toolkit for
understanding both things and medicine
is in the process of screwing up by not
being evolutionary which is a big part
of as you point out why you and I with
no budget sitting here just hashing
stuff out in front of a camera we're
able to beat all of these experts
because we have a model that was
actually relevant across the pandemic
evolution is relevant across the
pandemic it's relevant to the evolution
of the pathogen it is relevant to the
evolution of the immune response it is
relevant to the human body and the
Damage that is done to it by both
pathogens and by badly formulated
Pharmaceuticals the point is
it's not just another field it is a
baseline toolkit that works for any of
these complex systems that have this
adaptive feature at their core
and it should be updating medicine which
it is not doing
it's really really not yeah yeah
so you this week I believe uh had
uh a friend approach you with a a
question that felt to you like you could
you could use some of what you were
talking about last week to to continue
the conversation about model of science
the product of science being a model yep
a good friend uh sent me something that
they wanted my take on because it
stretched the bounds of crutility as far
as they were concerned and they wanted
to know whether or not it looked
different from from my perspective Zach
can you put up that uh tweet I sent you
yeah
oh it's a little hard to read uh you
want me to read it yeah would you read
it you can see it yeah
many people have been asking me how I
got my architis despite being
unvaccinated two days after spending
time with a friend who had just received
the vaccine my heart began to have uh
severe irregularities and took me a year
to recover vaccine shedding is a valid
concern and this is from an account uh
Dr Simon godek who is a Brazilian
um he is a he has a PHD it's not a
medical degree uh he's a technologist of
some kind and the question here is he's
reported a friend of his friend
forwarded this tweet and said basically
should I take this seriously and I
thought that this was an excellent place
to take our evolving model for a spin
right is this person reporting something
that we all ought to be concerned about
that is to say a recently vaccinated
person shedding something presumably uh
pseudo-iridine stabilized mrnas causing
myocarditis even though one was not
vaccinated
alarming if true
so I want to tell you a little bit about
the evolution of my understanding of the
shedding question so the shedding the
issue of shedding has been discussed for
a very long period of time since the
beginning of the vaccination campaign
people have reported yeah
um people have reported all kinds of
anecdotal stuff
now my understanding and I think it's
your understanding as well is that
there's something very unlikely about
the idea of being in close proximity to
a vaccinated person and being
importantly affected by something shed
by them just just just at the like
density dependence level of analysis
there's just not it doesn't seem like
there's enough of it well it seems like
there can't be enough of it for the
following reason
if a person is given the inoculation
they get a huge dose
hundreds of millions of particles
the amount that they could shed into the
environment would be a tiny fraction of
that so the point is if the stuff that a
person sheds into the environment is
itself
um
lethal right if this was you know
polonium-like or something then the
point is the dose that they got
themselves would have been so immense
that you would expect nobody to survive
it right so the point is one if you take
a standard model of
um of
just simply dosages and materials this
does not sound like a familiar material
that a person could get a huge amount of
it injected into them and shed enough of
it to cause a pathology in an adjacent
person right
um so anyway that was my initial doubt
I the day I met Robert Malone Robert
Malone came to our house to our studio
to do Dark Horse which is where I met
him yep instantly liked the guy right
instantly like the guy because he has
the same love of biology that you and I
do and the same interest in finding
somebody else who knows something about
the topic and playing back and forth
just volleying non-competitive very
interested in talking about anything you
might raise it doesn't show up with the
diploma going like I stopped learning
back in whenever it was I graduated and
I'm not I'm read only now right like
good scientists are never read only
right and you know also very much to his
credit any time that uh in my case
something I said to him challenged what
he had previously thought he would admit
in real time oh hadn't thought of it
that way that's interesting it might be
such and such and so and so anyway so I
asked him after the podcast I said look
I've been hearing a lot about the
shedding stuff what do you think and I
tried not to inform him of my
perspective so I don't think there was
any risk of polluting his perspective
but there would be
I wouldn't have to worry about it and he
was very dubious
about shedding now
okay so I went on from that point
thinking yeah there's something weird
about this shedding story it probably is
not a significant thing and I now have
not only the fact that my model says
it's very unlikely the dosage
consideration makes it unlikely but I
also have somebody who knows this topic
from a completely different perspective
who sees it the same way okay
I will say that after that the medical
dissidents
have taken on
increasing seriousness about the
question of shedding is there a shedding
phenomenon so that is to say in spite of
the fact that a standard model of
dosages would suggest this is unlikely
to be significant there is enough
pattern in the universe that
um causes people who were initially
dubious to wonder and there are in fact
some places in which shedding is
probably a significant factor things
like breastfeeding
blood transfusions
and potentially sex right right but that
none of those are shedding well they're
shedding but they're not shedding in the
sense of uh I mean it's it's fluid
exchange right exactly fluid exchange is
different from shedding exactly well
it's a subcategory but let's just say
that would make sense if there was some
consideration uh in places where where
fluid is exchanged
um but not in you know
breathing right the same space as
somebody for example okay so in any case
we've updated our model there are some
special cases which might have an
important relevance and I believe sadly
there is some evidence that suggests
there have been some injuries from this
but then we have a claim like the one in
this tweet now the one in the tweet I
don't want to fault the person who
uh reports this because they are
reporting something factual now I'm in
no position to check their facts but
what they're saying is that there is a
temporal
uh a temporal alignment of their
presence with a recently vaccinated
person and then this symptom showing up
which has been shown to be the product
of uh it's an adverse event that follows
mRNA vaccination
so the question is is there something
going on that suggests the model is
incomplete
is this person actually reporting an
adverse event from a inoculation that
they didn't get or not and so um I just
I can't I never saw this before and I'm
looking for it because I'd love to see
what you're talking about again here
um I will Zach would you just put it up
on the screen again uh the Tweet yeah
yep
um
two days after spending it's really hard
to see but they are our thing the way it
is right now uh two days after spending
time with a friend who just receive the
vaccine my heart began to have sphere
regularities and it took me a year to
recover
um
well I mean I I
again we don't know this person but I
don't know anything about his life but
um you know pointing pointing to a two
days after and then I've had a year of
sounds like a kind of temporal causality
but it doesn't say anything about all of
the other things that this person was
doing for you know those two days the
seven days before the month before any
of it right like did they did they have
coveted right like you know there's all
sorts of things that might have been
true and so you know it's it's it's it's
a very selective story as stories always
are right but uh but but it but it it
certainly doesn't demonstrate anything
with the kind of assurance that the tone
suggests right well this demonstrates
nothing we agree yeah with that the
question is could it be indicative of
something it could is it likely to be
indicative of something I don't think so
now if we go back to the model of
vaccine injury that uh that I presented
the model whereby the transfection of
cells around the body haphazardly
results in the immune system attacking
the cells that are making this foreign
protein because the immune system
effectively assumes that those cells
have been virally infected and it is
programmed to destroy virally infected
cells
is that likely to be going on here as a
result of shedding and could it be
causing this myocarditis and here's what
I would say and what I said to the the
friend in question
dosage suggests that that is near
impossible
that it is not impossible that a
stabilized mRNA could escape a
vaccinated person be taken in by
breathing or some other mechanism by
somebody who hadn't been vaccinated
could transfect a cell and that that
cell could be destroyed by the immune
system
but the point is the degree of harm that
would come from a small number of these
instances would be so tiny that it would
be undetectable in fact
when a really good vaccine is based on
the technology of attenuation an
attenuated virus vaccine infect cells
and the immune system does kill them
right and the point is there's not a
pathology that comes from a good vaccine
because it's a small number of cells it
may be Millions but it's a small number
of cells right there's cell death and so
the point is if you're if you were able
to measure finally enough is it possible
that somebody could shed a particle that
would have this impact on a cell that
would cause the loss of a heart cell in
the worst case yeah but you wouldn't
notice it so I don't think that
myocarditis could be caused by this
could I be wrong absolutely and I will
tell you how I could be wrong on this
but my basic point is if the thing
functions the way we think it does this
story does not function it does not it
is not causally explanatory and what I
would say is remember I every time I
talk about this topic I say remember
that myocarditis itis means inflammation
right
the reason that myocarditis is being
caused by these mRNA vaccines we now
effectively know this based on what
we've seen based on what we've showed
last week for example
is that there is damage to the heart
damage done when transfected cells are
attacked by the immune system and
destroyed right it's like a burn inside
the heart or any other tissue and it
will be every other tissue every tissue
that is perfused with blood and takes up
these particles
but
itis is a syndrome it's a symptom it is
not the disease itself so the point is
this person reporting that they had
myocarditis that's not a high degree of
specificity it doesn't say that it's the
same kind of myocarditis it's a symptom
of infestation it's a manifestation now
myocarditis is serious yeah right this
person had a serious something from some
cause right but it is unlikely to be the
thing that causes people who have taken
in large numbers of these mRNA uh good
particles
to have myocarditis which is to say an
internal burn of of their heart right
now okay so basically the point here is
really about well what do you do with a
model well you've now heard a model
about what these Adverse Events are
that model says that this story about
somebody shedding particles and causing
the same phenomenon in an unvaccinated
person unlikely to be true at least not
by the same mechanism
okay so that's what the model does it
allows you to extrapolate does that give
you certainty absolutely not and then I
would say I would open up another Branch
here and I would say if it turned out
that there was a pattern that people who
had been in proximity to those who had
been transffected without having been
transfected themselves showed this
pattern of damage consistent with having
been transfected
how is that possible right I'm not
saying this is true but what would I
think if I saw that it wasn't one person
reporting this but it was a pattern that
had been consistently demonstrated
then I would have to say well you need
something that would amplify the harm of
a small number of particles right
something akin to a prion disease
so a prion disease is one in which and
by the way there is a whole interesting
topic to be explored as to whether or
not prions are really uh pathogens or
whether they are just a strange kind of
self-propagating error right but put
that aside for a second a prion is a
distinction
that you're making here being that
pathogen in your dictionary that you've
just
implied uh is benefiting from its
engagement with host whereas some
self-replicating error is just existing
without any
um any any benefit or cost to itself
from its interaction with host yeah so
the really what I'm evoking is there's
an evolutionary phenomenon going on when
you have a prior on a prion is a folding
of a protein that is contagious in the
pathogenic case you have a misfolding of
a protein that causes other proteins
with the same sequence to misfold the
same way so like uh mad cow disease
but the question is
is this effectively a kind of life that
doesn't have any uh DNA or RNA in it
that the information is the fold and it
is actually evolving and it's our true
pathogen or is this a kind of Quirk the
way cancer is Right cancers evolve but
most cancers are not contagious and
therefore the fact that you get a cancer
is you know your own uh systems failure
to control a kind of runaway process
it's not uh cancer isn't trying to kill
you now there are Cancers it does raise
the question of like what what is
different in those few cancers that are
contagious right right like the the one
that afflicts the Tasmanian devils
that's the only one that I can come up
with there are there are several but
there are um it's definitely as far as
we know the exception and not the rule
and the public health pattern does not
reflect that it's anything other than an
exception so but anyway point being a
contagious misfolding is the kind of
thing that could take a tiny dose of
something and turn it into a serious
problem just the same way that a virus
you may get a tiny number of particles
one of those particles gets through all
of the defenses and then that particle
creates billions of copies of itself
creating a pathology right the one
particle would be incapable of doing it
but the fact that it copies itself
causes these pathologies so anyway long
and short of it is hey models are cool
you get a model of the Adverse Events
and then you can say well here I'm
hearing a report of an adverse event
does it match the model nope it
certainly would be in conflict with the
model it might need a separate model and
if it needed a separate model it would
have to look like something with an
amplifier in it so let's assume this is
a odd Coincidence of a person who just
happened to get myocarditis from some uh
other influence that temporarily was
unfortunately connected to their
proximity to some transfected person but
should the pattern turn up in a
systematic way that demands an
explanation where to look for
explanations amplifiers
mhm amplifiers good yeah I think that's
that's an excellent
example of how to use how to use the
model so I'm going to keep on punting
because you wanted you wanted to do a
bunch of stuff this week and you're up
next you're up next okay next we will
Annex Europe is that what you mean no
not even the Sudan land
oh boy no I think um
I'm glad I'm glad you said it yeah not
me because I'm the one with the German
Heritage yeah just it's too soon it's
always too soon yeah it's all it's
always too soon it'll always be too soon
yes true it will always be too soon so
but we did want to talk about race yes
of course it's that time in the podcast
apparently yeah yeah um yeah I wanted to
talk about something and unfortunately I
have to break us out of you know as with
a person who was in close proximity to
somebody transfected we have to break
ourselves out of the obvious connection
here which is irrelevant to what I want
to talk about
the connection is I want to talk about
what unfolded with Scott Adams this week
and we have of course talked about Scott
Adams in recent podcasts and this is for
I want to talk about this for a totally
different reason this has nothing to do
with our ongoing uh
disagreement with Scott about why it is
that we were right about covet right he
thinks it was lucky guesses we think
it's models
um and by the way we're right um but in
any case put that aside Scott Adams
became big news again this week because
he said something rather remarkable on
his own daily podcast
um Zach do you want to show it yep
yep I've accidentally joined a hate
group
so if if you know nearly half of All
Blacks
are not okay with white people according
to this poll not according to me
according to this poll
uh that's a hate group
that's a hate group
and I don't want to have anything to do
with them
and I would say you know based on the
current way things are going the best
advice I would give to white people is
to get the hell away from black people
just get the [__] away
wherever you have to go just get away
because there's no fixing this
okay now
um I want us to put aside our initial
reaction to the content of what he says
it's very shocking right he's
effectively arguing for a kind of
um segregation self-segregation by race
and he's doing so on the basis of a poll
a Rasmussen poll
and
what I want to resist doing it's very
easy to take pot shots at him after he
says something like this but I really
want to pursue this a little bit deeper
because it has a deeper implication
um
the poll in question reports that
something under 50 but not weigh under
50 percent
of black people
say uh do not resonate with the
statement that it is okay to be white
that's that's the thing yeah do
you resonate with the statement they do
not agree that it is okay to be white
47 with uh 95 confidence that it's
within three points
um the same poll
also asked whether or not
um but so people who aren't white are
being asked
is it okay to be white yes not is it a
I'm confused
well I mean it is a confusing moment
that such a question would make any
freaking sense is
um
yeah I mean like sure at one level it's
like okay with a pool if you is it okay
to be human like I don't what I am
and right like so is it okay to be an
Earthling
what yeah but right but it's like but I
don't so I don't get what was this uh
was this a poll that was sort of across
all Americans and then they also took
data on race and then and it was a tiny
little poll thousand people
um total yeah of which some fraction of
that were black people yep and almost
half of them said uh I do not agree with
the statement it is okay to be white
correct now the same poll okay uh asked
um
oh can black people be racist and 79
uh agreed that black people can be
racist 79 of the entire pool or of black
people I believe 79 of black people I
would have to go back and look carefully
but nonetheless this is a tiny poll okay
a tiny pole and with a suspect
methodology very easy to screw up a poll
that is a combination of a phone pole
and a online survey right so not a huge
study
sounds total garbage yeah total garbage
but nonetheless it's 2023 right somehow
we have landed in a place where the
question of whether or not it is okay to
be white is somehow not laughable on its
face
um so that is an interesting fact well I
mean so this is going to seem totally
far afield but like I'm not I cannot see
this I'm not familiar with this
obviously I don't know anything about
the poll but the idea that like okay the
methods are garbage and the question
being asked is garbage as well that like
that sounds like where have we seen that
before like that sounds like medical
research and scientific research like oh
not only is the question you asked
nonsensical in the context of the
environment in which we are living but
also your methods had absolutely no way
of determining whether or not uh
yeah absolutely no way of answering the
question right well let's just point to
one obvious bias here okay the survey
will obviously be biased in the
direction of those who are more likely
to voice an opinion right and so it may
be that opinionated people are heavily
biased in the direction of having an
extreme view for example and that this
doesn't in any way represent the sum
total most people might just think well
yeah of course why would I you know why
would I participate yeah what does that
question even mean so but the reason
that I raise it
uh there is a
podcast that I did at the very beginning
of Dark Horse long before the live
streams I believe uh in which I
pointed out
that one of the hazards of the
um woke emphasis on race and the
demonizing of the concept of what they
call whiteness was that it was going to
drive white people together and that
that was going to be a disaster not only
for everybody but especially for people
who aren't white that this was going to
effectively take this potentially
powerful you know lineage or pseudo
lineage
and it was going to inflame it and cause
it to gather and because it's a majority
uh you know compared to any compared to
the next largest lineage in the US at
least that that was going to be an
extremely dangerous thing to do so it
was uh it was a warning from me saying
don't do this this is gum especially if
your concern is the well-being of people
who uh are from Minority populations you
are creating the very coalitions that
you would have us believe are the most
dangerous coalitions that exist right
and Scott Adams is giving voice to the
thing that will cause people to gather
what he says in this clip is literally
look if people aren't okay with white
folks then I suggest white folks get
away from them now he screws up
a what he said and he should recognize
it is deeply un-American
it is deeply Un-American that we should
be getting away from some population
because among the many special things
about this country
um perhaps the most special is the
experiment in which we attempt to put
aside lineage level considerations and
to live together as a collaborative
people right and so what he's saying oh
I just want to get away from those
people if they're not cool with me is
exactly the opposite of what his
response should be
is a patriotic American his point should
be holy hell if that's real
what can we do about it right I would
also point out that even if the poll is
accurate as they did it like let's just
say that none of the methodological
methodological considerations end up
being important and that it is somehow
representative
well it still means that a majority of
black people do think it's okay to be
white and so the idea that the right
reaction to a large minority of any
group coming to this also deeply
Un-American conclusion is to abandon the
entire population and go isolating your
own racial group is insane right the
point is this is an all hands on deck
moment right we need to confront the
woke ideology that is attempting to
demonize so-called whiteness and we need
to confront this instinct to well if
that's what you're going to do then
we're going to X right
there's
we are such a confused people
um
there are
immutable characteristics
sex is one of them
your ancestry is one of them and that
Maps very imperfectly onto sort of
public Renditions of what race you are
right no one is pure
anything almost right like actually I'll
just like no one is pure anything
there's no pure Bloods right like that's
that's an that's an insanity but there
are you know there are people who are
more Lithuanian than anything else and
people who are more you know African
origin than anything else who are in
America and therefore African-Americans
you know this this is this is true and
this cannot change
like you are you are what your history
was and you are what you know if you're
a mammal uh the sperm that contributed
half of its gen half of what is now your
genetic complement to making you who you
are determined whether you are male or
female
and those things don't change and so the
idea that we
could be talking about whether it's okay
to be something that you're born as
we live in the age of original sin like
what what is this what what kind of
garbage is this and then at the same
time you've got you know after power
conversation last week
people saying well you know people are
just born with these predilections that
are like
horrible like pedophilia and like what
can you do you just got to accept them
you can't shame them for you know having
these having these feelings that they
have you know there's there's nothing to
be done about it's like you know what
that thing
not foundational not fundamental not
about your lineage and also I Hazard to
guess not immutable so so no we don't
you know we don't use shame we would
never advocate for shame around
something that
you are you are born with it is
something it is fundamental to who you
are
and instead we've got we've flipped
these things we're shaming people for
their lineage
we're pretending they can change the sex
that they are
and we're embracing people's Kinks which
are fundamentally bad for society
one two three wrong wrong wrong like how
do we get here
you know who has a really good model
that helps sort this out
we do here get that book this book yeah
that book yeah okay yeah so in in this
book yeah we talk about the distinction
between the software layer and the
hardware layer and you may or may not
love that distinction I happen to think
it's super uh elegant and that the fact
that it works even when you start to
pursue it well what about the firmware
level yeah we got that too
um you know the point is we do function
this way and we humans
are the extreme case of a creature with
dual inheritance right we inherit the
genetic stuff which as you point out you
can't do anything about it you know it's
whatever happens to come together
between sperm and Ag and then we get a
software package loaded on you know are
we a blank slate no but well but that's
to
I think in part people get confused
because the software Hardware analogy
isn't perfect because the software is is
the mutable part the fungible part the
plastic part right the software
um from you know day one is in is
beginning to be informed by the
environment well I guess on day one
you're still up maybe in the Fallopian
tubes I don't remember exactly the
timing but call it you know day 14 of of
a zygote and the uterine environment is
affecting how development happens and
you know there's there's a reason that
morning sicknesses and morning sickness
and uh aversions and Cravings during
pregnancy are what they are and that's
the zygotes and then the fetus's way of
communicating to Mom hey I need more of
this or like no not that that's gonna
hurt me right so that you know that that
is all the developing software and so
unlike
Microsoft Word right where you bring it
in and you can say oh well I you know I
actually want to see this in my ribbon
and this in my toolbar
um we we are changing much more about
what we are yeah but I mean we don't
need to get tied up in this but my point
would be all you got to do is then say
well how good an analogy is that and
then pursue it into the computer layer
and you find out well the same thing is
true there not identically so but you
know the the software that gets loaded
on to the underlying computer by the
manufacturer before you get around to
deciding what software you want to put
onto the thing the point is it it's
there and you've got an underlying
Hardware layer that is uh
predisposed to emerge through genes
about which you can do nothing and then
you've got every layer of flexibility in
the software layer from not much
flexibility at all up through perfectly
flexible
and it all it all works but anyway
you're right the point is we've reverse
the order we're now shaming people for
the stuff that they can't change and we
are refusing to shame them for the stuff
that they really must change and that is
an indicative of something is indicative
of the fact that these conclusions are
not based on some deep model of reality
what they are is about power
right it is very powerful to take
something that somebody cannot change
and decide that it is a reason to shun
them right because the point is they
can't you know show up one day and say
well I've dealt with it deal with me
it's like no you're still White
you still suck you know you are
obligated to spend all your time getting
over your whiteness and you know what
it's never going to work so go away and
work on that project and get back to me
at the point that uh well you can't
because it's unfixable except uh the the
ideology comes to uh
a somehow an equally absurd but almost
opposite conclusion over in sex space
right oh you can cure the problem of
having been born male because how dare
you by putting on lipstick and heels and
asking to be called Martha
what did you just do and why what on
Earth are half-ish of the country doing
going along with it nodding going like
yeah yeah you you go girl
what is happening right no it it's
absurd and you know I don't know how
many times we're going to see this
pattern right it's one thing to not
understand anything and to have a random
response it's another thing to invert
reality and to take the immutable and
treat it as perfectly plastic and to
take the perfectly plastic and treated
as immutable
you know that's not just wrong it's
upside down of right you know and it's
upside down of right and I think to get
back to
you know this question of like oh well
will the hate campaign that's
masquerading as loving tenderness and
book ideology
um cause segregation which in turn will
cause ever greater division
um yeah yeah it will and
and is it
better for us to be interested in
hanging out with people who aren't
exactly like us yes
are we obliged to do that all the time
no are we in fact obliged to do whatever
no
but uh do we find our worlds enhanced
and better in every regard when we do
this holds for sex for race for religion
for politics for level of education for
trade for you know career for you know
basically across the board right so does
that mean that you should never ever
ever hang out with people like you like
you shouldn't go to a conference for
biologists or hang out in an all-women
space or
have a friend group that is all black
and sometimes say you know what it's us
going to be here today and love you but
like not you today it's going to be us
that's all good too yep right like we we
actually can have that both ways we can
know that it's better to as a life
choice be embracing of actual difference
like actual diversity be inclusive of
actual diversity while also allowing for
people to make individual choices that
hopefully don't make art this sum of all
of their choices in which they say right
now because I need to learn more
accounting I'm going to go hang out with
the accountants and right now because
this is where my headspace is right now
you know you're going to go hang out
with a bunch of men and right now you
know I'm gonna hang out with a bunch of
you know ukrainians whatever it is right
like that's also okay you can you can
have it you can't have this both ways
and somehow we're being told
any choice that we make if we have
certain immutable characteristics is is
inherently wrong and uh and and we have
to go along with the fantasies of crazy
people yeah
um
I would also point out that those who
are most likely to just simply narrowly
take Scott Adams to task for his uh
an American Outburst uh
are also likely to be people who have
caused the problem this is why I
delivered that warning all that years
ago all those years ago that if you do
this if you demonize people over their
race whether that race is understood to
be a privileged one or not you are going
to reinvent this problem which we had
not solved but we were definitely on our
way to solving it yeah the West had
understood correctly that the right
thing to be is a colorblind Society
colorblind not meaning that we don't
notice each other's color it means that
it is not an indicator of your
likelihood of success it does not it
does not predispose you to succeed in a
court of law or a classroom or anything
it's just a simple fact like your hair
color or your language of
of your birth now I'm going to take one
objection there because I do think
that some of the language that we use uh
easily is maybe contributing to the
conclusion to the confusion which is
that in this case
um we hadn't solved it
um what I will tend to say is but we
were moving in the right direction and I
I really honestly believe that that
we're moving pretty fast in the right
direction we were it was getting ever
better
um but I would say not I think what you
said was
um
we might have solved it or we could have
solved it or something like that and and
I and I know that you don't think that
there's a static solution to be had and
you know maybe it's an asymptote but
even if it's an asymptote that asymptote
itself will move because you know people
are people are going to people no no no
no no no I don't I don't agree with this
the asymptote is the line of formal
color blindness of your Society you're
allowed to be any color it's allowed to
have its implications but in some
individuals are gonna gonna not buy in
well but the point is the asymptote is
the degree to which everybody is on
board with the idea that your color
ought not predispose you to succeed in
any context it's just a simple fact of
who you are it's not um it's not a
predictive fact on the basis that you
have advantages coming from One race or
another so anyway the asymptote is US
collectively by reaching a place where
you know you know basically the
asymptote is uh Martin Luther King Jr's
uh I have a dream right it is you are
judged on the content of your character
and not the color of your skin
and you know the degree to which we are
at the or approaching the asymptote is
the degree to which everybody's on board
with that
okay
all right
um
you feel like we've uh we've arrived at
the uh
sure I I it's more question for you this
week I think uh
I feel like you got where you wanted to
go yeah I think
um I think we I think we've done it
all right
so we will come back with a live q a in
about 15 minutes and we will also be
back a week from now uh in a week when
we come back we will not be doing a q a
next week but we will be back at the
usual time uh doing our live stream on
Saturday at noon 30 Pacific uh in the
meantime if you have questions that you
want to ask in the Q a you can ask them
at darkhorsesmissions.com if you want to
join us for a a more intimate
conversation for two hours starting at
11 A.M Pacific tomorrow that's Sunday
February something 26th yeah it's gonna
be February yeah for a couple more days
I think it's the 26th tomorrow it must
be yes
um we're going to be doing that at my
patreon
and
um yeah I think actually more than more
than usual in this conversation we
brought this book up a lot here so
that's I'm off screen fine there we go
it's Hunter gathers Guide to the 21st
century
um
we uh we encourage you to read it it's
available in all sorts of languages now
as well uh until we see you next time be
good to the ones you love eat good food
and get outside be well everyone
[Music]
thank you
foreign